Okay,
welcome to the DDPS seminar. Everyone. Before
I introduce today's speaker, let me go over
some rules and logistics. First of all, please
mute yourself here in the talk, but if you have
questions, you can unmute and ask questions or
use chat room to post your questions so that you
can address them at the end second. Today's DDK
seminar is open to external audiences. No plus
five discussion is allowed, so please watch
out. Finally, the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about
it. Let me briefly introduce our speaker today.
It's a great honor to host Professor Max welling,
who is a full professor and Research Chair in
machine learning at the University of Amsterdam,
and a working distinguished visiting professor at
Caltech. He is co founder and a co founder of the
startup CUSP AI in materials design. He's a fellow
at the Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
and the European lab for learning and intelligence
systems, where he served on the founding board
his previous appointment
includes partner and VP at
Microsoft Research and VP at Qualcomm
technology, professor at UCR fine.
He finished his PhD in theoretical High
Energy Physics on the supervision of Nobel
Prize winner Professor Gerald right, and he then
switched fields to focus on machine learning,
first as a postdoc at Caltech on the supervision
of Professor Kirito Corona and then a postdoc on
the supervision of another Nobel Prize winner,
Professor Jeffrey Hinton at UCL and the UC 20
today, Max will talk about his AI
shifting the paradigm of scientific
discovery. I'm sure we are going
to hear a wonderful talk today.
Now let me ask a
informal questions and then move on to fun part.
So today's informal question is, Max, I know that
as I introduce today, you've been studying the
physics first, right? And then somehow move on to
the machine learning. And you must be fascinated
by some aspect of the machine learning. That's why
you transition from physics. If you can tell
us briefly about how that transition happens.
Yeah. Thank you very much for the introduction.
I'm happy to be here. We have people
online which are not muted, so I'm sure.
And
so indeed, so I did my PhD in two dimensional
quantum gravity, and I didn't quite see that's
going to make the impact in the world. And
so I wanted to do something where I would
warn impact. And so machine learning was,
at that point, a budding field with maybe
people training models with a few 10s to hundreds
of parameters, not trillions, as we do now.
And so I started working on that, but, and that's
also the reason, ultimately, why I started,
you know, startups like cost of AI, which is
to make an actual, real impact, and not just
a theoretical impact, with papers. I'll talk
about that a little bit today, but ironically,
I've gone full circle going back to physics,
material science, but also I'm very interested
in quantum mechanics. I think the fundamentals
of quantum mechanics and quantum computing. So
I won't talk about that, but today I'll talk
about machinery for molecules and materials.
Yeah, so I'll start my talk by
talking about two revolutions which have happened
over the course of sort of humanity, sort of not
the first one, but very impactful one was the
Industrial Revolution, where human labor was
being replaced by machine labor. And it was,
of course, it resulted in what we have today, but
including all the pollution that this generated,
because we, of course, we needed to drill
for oil and gas and other fossil fuels
in order to power the revolution.
And it's that which is currently,
oh, sorry,
sorry.
I'm sorry we have a little technical
difficulty. There we go back.
So we need to power that revolution with
fossil fuels, which ultimately also caused the.
A large amount of carbon dioxide in the in the
atmosphere at this point. And so now today,
we are looking at an information revolution
which is replacing mental human labor by
machine mental labor, if you wish, which is,
of course, the AI revolution. And the hope is
that maybe the AI revolution could help also
clean up the mess from the from the previous
revolution. So here's a little graph, which is
the carbon dioxide levels in the atmosphere. This
is 7064 which is the invention of the steam
engine, and the levels of carbon dioxide and
global temperature. In fact, what shown here are
rising right after that. This is my birth year,
so in some sense, our generation, I'd say
my generation, has been benefiting from the
fact that we can dig up fossil fuels
and use them. And it's also up to us,
I feel, to hand over the world to the
next generation in a more clean state,
which is we need to start removing carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere, which is a technology that
currently doesn't really exist at the scale
that we needed. So here are some here's a graph
which shows some scenarios which are necessary to
stay within 1.5 to two degrees. It seems you're
already at 1.5 by the way, but let's
say two or 1.5 degrees global warming,
which means that we have to decrease the amount
of emissions in the atmosphere, and by 2050 we
need to be completely carbon neutral under all of
these scenarios. Now, I would say these scenarios
should go down in carbon dioxide under I would
say currently, the way the world is moving,
I don't see this coming down at all. So it will
hopefully be a more sharp peak at some point.
But we will have to be carbon neutral at 2015
but after that, and this is basically replacing
sort of fossil fuel with sustainable energy
sources. But after that, there is a century,
or at least half a century, but
more like a century of having to
remove carbon dioxide from the atmosphere at
half the rate that we're putting it in. Now,
that technology at that scale does absolutely not
exist, but all of these scenarios count on that,
and so that needs to be developed, in my view, in
order to not go into crazy global warming. And so
the hope is that technology and AI can help
us achieve that. And so I think we are at the
cusp of somewhat of a revolution in AI using an
AI in the sciences. And of course, in this lab,
people realize that if I look at all these photos
here, which are all about how AI will help change
scientific simulation and stuff like that. So
you're all into this, I'm sure. So I sort of
identified two steps for this to happen, or these
are basically happening right now. The first step
is to replace pieces and bits and pieces and bits
and pieces of experiment to computer simulation.
So experiments are expensive and slow, and the
more you can do in a computer, the faster you
can go through design cycles and all that. So
of course, the compute is growing exponentially,
and that's good. And so we are going from
basically just trial error in experiment,
to do lots of experiments and storing the data,
analyzing it, maybe with statistics and machine
learning techniques, to a stage where we
do all the simulations of the molecules,
literally, the actual simulation of
the molecule in silico. That's the
first step. And then the second step is
going from simulation to emulation. So
here's an example in fluid dynamics.
So you're a car designer, you test
your car in a wind tunnel by already
made the first transition. So you're
not testing it in a real wind tunnel, but
you're doing it in a digital wind tunnel.
And then we design your next car, instead
of just redoing that process and just going
through the same expensive simulation, you
could have stored the data from the first one,
then train the neural network to
either accelerate this particular
simulation or actually directly predict
the relevant properties. In other words,
machine learning is providing a shortcut
for these kinds of simulations. Of course,
one big challenge is to do it in a reliable
way, so that you will actually also,
if you go slightly out of the domain that you
will be able you will have reliable predictions.
And so, you know, this kind of
revolution is happening across
all the scales of scientific research,
all the way in particle physics,
where you talk about pico meters and femtoseconds,
all the way up to astrophysics, where you
talk about light years and picometers.
Now in this talk, I'll be
touching on two of these,
but I acknowledge this is just a small
slice of where you know, where you can.
Do. The first one is simulating
molecules, and the second one is
something about simulating fluids. First,
a little bit about molecules. Why am I very
interested in molecules? Well, they are basically
the root of everything. If you can control,
simulate and control molecules, you can solve
a lot of society's biggest problems. Of course,
drug discovery is one. Photo cells is another.
Better lubricants. 20% of all our energy
losses seem to be due to friction. So that
lubricants can help. There better
catalysts, which are, of course,
underneath all chemical reactions. And then, you
know, here's a here's a process like nitrogen
fixation for fertilizers and carbon capture,
which you just mentioned, which is important.
Okay, so now, what are the challenges in
molecular assimilation? I'll first talk a
little bit about molecular simulation. So what
are the challenges in molecular simulation?
So a molecule at a very
rough, sketchy sort of level,
is a bunch of atoms or ions connected by
bonds, plus a electron cloud around it.
I do have a clue, but
I cannot
now, what are the three challenges
for molecular simulation?
So the first one is basically, in order to
evolve the molecule forward in time, it's
just in principle, using Newtonian dynamics, which
is the change in position, is given by velocity,
and the change in velocity is given by force.
The problem, the first problem appears because
the force is largely quantum mechanical, due
to the electrons, right? So this gives you
very hard computation to do, as you don't
approximate it. The second one is, this is
a highly chaotic system. It's a highly nonlinear
set of equations, ODEs, if you wish, that needs
to be evolved. And very quickly, of course,
this becomes chaotic. And the third one is,
if you want to design materials, the search space
is humongous, 10 to the 60 at least, but possibly
larger. And so how do you effectively search
through the space of molecules and materials.
Now here's a few examples of things I've worked
at, but also where the where the field, sort of
has started to make contributions. And so on
this side, we have the time dependent Schrodinger
equation, where the green wall is the sort of
electron cloud. This is beautiful visualization
by quantum magazine. And here's a time
dependent Schrodinger equation. And then we have
ideas to take the functional for a DFT,
which is a functional of the density,
electron density, and you have to write
down something for that. And now people
have started to train machine learning models
for this DFT functional and the other one
is quantum variational Monte Carlo, which is
another technique for solving this equation.
And people have also started to use
neural networks in quantum very in
quantum variation Monte Carlo, and the
examples of that are Fermi net and polynet
at one level up, we do actually do long
dynamics. This is water being simulated,
and you use the Langevin equation
for that, which is again,
neutron dynamics. Change in position is velocity.
Change in velocity is given by a friction term,
a friction term and a force term, and then
random noise. And it's this term which is hard
that people have started to build neural networks
to replace their quantum mechanical calculation,
or you typically do it with a DFT calculation,
and that's called the machinery and force field.
And I'll say a little bit more next. So this is
something I hope also have some time to talk to
you about. This is DFT, but for thermodynamics,
so it's a DFT calculated method, which is almost
perfect analogy of the DFT for quantum mechanics.
But then for thermodynamics, again, you have to
write down a functional. You don't know what the
functional is, and because people have written
down rather simple things, these methods didn't
work very well, but now you stick in the neural
network, and now it starts to work really well.
And we'll show you some results. And then there's,
of course, the Navier Stokes equation for
predicting the weather. This is a simple version
of it. There's huge amounts of data available
for this, which therefore super successful place
for applying machine learning. And we've
trained when the Microsoft, we've trained
a large model Aurora to predict
the future stage of the weather
by solving it all as a neural network,
not even worrying about the physics. And
then there's beautiful applications.
So there's models that can get.
Generate drug like molecules in the
pockets of acidic protein to develop
new drugs. There is the design of new catalysts to
accelerate chemical reactions. And quite recently,
the paper was published in Nature for the
diffusion models for generating materials.
This is the paper matter Gen from
Microsoft that would just generate materials,
and you can prompt them with certain properties,
and that will generate the materials for you. So
there's a these are all new, new techniques where
machine learning is sort of, I would say, changing
or disrupting this field of atomic simulations in
search. And so he has sort of rewritten a little
bit sort of a hierarchy of all the things that
people do in the chemistry and physics community,
all the way from Ebenezer electronic structure
methods to molecular simulations, and of course
bringing them to particle based simulations. And
of course bringing particle simulations all the
way to classical density functional theory and
continual methods, which is solving PDEs. And for
each one of these, there is now a machine learning
method that helps improve it, right? Quantum
Monte Carlo, the quantum DFT force field methods,
and then force fields for all of these. And
classical DFT, where I'll talk about a bit
in these PD circuit models, which are these
methods for weather prediction. And so we are,
we are seeing a sort of a real change in this
field, where we accelerate the simulation
by by using machine learning methods.
And so now I'll do a quick digression,
because I need some concepts to tell you
a little bit more about some of these
techniques. So the first one is symmetries and
how to build them into neural networks. Now,
symmetries play an incredibly important role, as
you all know, in physics, you can basically derive
Special Relativity from, from, from a few simple
symmetry arguments, like the Lorentz invariance,
and you can derive Maxwell's equations
by unifying electricity and magnetism.
By basically changing frames. You can
turn magnetism into electricity and back,
but just moving observers and thinking
about what observers see. Very powerful
tool in physics. You know, even even general
relativity can be derived from this equivalence
principle that gravity is sort
of the same as it's exactly the
same as acceleration. And even the Standard
Model of particles is governed, of course,
by symmetry groups. The different particles are
different.
You say you can you can rotate, or you can turn
one particle state into another particle state by
a symmetry which and that sort of gives you
the organization of fundamental particles.
So now in neural networks, though, it wasn't
very obvious how to use these symmetries,
right? So you could train a
neural network which would say,
predict, for me, let's say, the
energy and the forces on atoms
from you give it the current state of the atom,
and you want to predict the forces
so you can move it sort of along it.
Now it's clear that if you would rotate a molecule
in space, or you would move a molecule in space,
it would give you the same energy, and it would
rotate all the forces. So that's not if you know
the first solution, you just know the second one
for a rotated frame. The neural network, however,
doesn't know about that, so it would consider
a molecule input and a rotated molecule input
as a completely different, new problem, and needs
to learn how to produce forces for that. And the
output, if you didn't train it long enough, with
building up data, would actually not be a perfect
rotation. And so with typo Cohen and Maurice
Wyler later, and a whole bunch of other students
and postdocs, we studied how to take the symmetry
principle and put it into a neural net. And the
underlying, core mathematical idea is this idea of
equivariance, which says, Here's the equation, but
here's the picture, that you take an input image
and you translate it, and then you convolve it,
or just filter it to get you the first layer of
a neural net that should be the same as Phil's
first filtering and then translating, if you put
constraints so this, this closing of this diagram,
is commuting of this diagram and put constraints
on what this filters, filter maps can be. If you
restrict your neural network to have this kind of
property, then you're guaranteed that whatever you
do at the end has the has the symmetry property
of the of the group that you're interested in,
and so if you're interested in that, this
is an excellent book written by Maurice,
and, you know, and other co authors,
but mostly by Maurice, I would say.
And he has beautifully not just
written the book in sort of.
Hierarchical section, where the first chapter is
very high level, and then it goes into two deeper
and deeper levels, but it's also very richly and
beautifully illustrated. So this is the perfect
introduction into this field if you're
interested in learning more about this.
And so we also worked on graph neural
networks, because obviously a an image
is a regular you could represent as
a regular grid, but a molecule isn't
nicely represented as a regular grid. It's more
like a graph where the atoms are the nodes and
then the interactions are at the edges of the
graph. The only problem is, is that it's not
so clear how to do a convolution on a graph.
This has to do with the fact that in a graph,
if I just move a particular node, drag it to some
other place and change the order, the convolution
shouldn't change, but the representation,
if you don't take the right representation,
it will change. And also, it should be able
to handle an arbitrary number of neighbors,
not just a fixed number like in a regular group.
And so we, with Thomas KIPP, actually, first,
we developed this idea of a graph neural
network that is able to send these messages
in these graphs, so to do a convolution on a
graph. And later, with the Victor and Emile,
we also turn this into sort of a
more equivariant version of that.
So now here you have a graph. You do
your message passing on the graph,
then, or message passing, or convolution, if
you issue, then you rotate the molecule. And
so now this thing is, if you, if you do
message passing and rotate the molecules,
you would give you the same as
rotating the molecule and then
doing the math spaci And so now you have
an equivariant model for graph convolutions
that is fully equivariant and therefore
appropriate for modeling molecules. Here's
a bunch of equations. So just to show this
actually doesn't have to be complicated.
So one of these equations to make to
get this to be equit doesn't have to
be complicated. So here's two papers that
we wrote among others about how to take
that idea and turn this into a force field,
right? So this is the SE three test form,
which is a model that was actually used
by David Baker in his work on proteins
or zip fold. And something similar was
in the first versions of alpha fold,
and then another one steerable, equivariant
message passing for force fields.
And so these methods are completely
equivariant. And basically that means
that if you, if you rotate in the
frame, or they rotate the molecule,
nothing changes. And so what you see here
is over time passing messages. And these are
sort of our harmonic representations,
visualized as you sort of sending
these messages over the over the graph.
And now the nice thing is that
these machinery force fields,
they sit between ab initio, DFT calculations
to do the forces which are very expensive,
so you can only do very small molecules, and
classical force fields which are inaccurate,
but you can do large molecules. And so this
machine learning force was sort of starting to
span this field. So they can do large molecules,
but also at the level of DFT accuracy, and there's
quite a few efforts around, also in big tech
companies, to build these basically foundation
models for these force fields, which should
work across a large swath of chemical space. And
of course, maybe the main example
of why this field is blooming
is the fact that the Nobel Prize was
awarded two chemistry biologists,
computational chemistry biologists, who have
both solved the problem, or sort of
make a huge amount of progress On the
problem of going from sequence to three
dimensional structure, which is alpha
four, of course, or take the structure
and design the sequence that would have that
structure, which would be designed probably.
And so I think this year's
Nobel Prize is a sign that
this is an important field that will
deliver a lot of interesting results.
OK, so that's for molecular science,
and I will discuss a few more things
later. In a little bit more detail.
There's this other field which is also
being disrupted or going very strong,
with machine learning, which is P E, solve,
solving. And it started, you know, this paper
by Stephen Hauer and a bunch of other co authors
by basically taking a usual solver and starting
to look at places where you can replace certain
bits and pieces of it, stencils, for instance,
with machine learning stencils, you could just
learn your own stencils to solve this equation.
But otherwise, you'll keep the solver the same.
You just keep the same solver which is new.
Improve some of the pieces of it, and slowly
that evolved into things which were starting
to remove more and more of the physics, and in
particular in fields where there's lots of data,
you can afford to remove the physics. And so
there's these deep operator networks, and then
there's four operators. These are all examples
of basically removing the physics and just
training a model that maps into some latent space,
evolves the system in latent space as a recurrent
neural network and then predates back the next
state. Now there's also attempts, of course,
to try to bring back some of the physics.
And this is this pin structure physics,
important neural networks, where the
actual equations of motion and the
possibly Boundary conditions can all be enforced
as regularizers on these on these solvers.
So again, so it's a very fast holding field.
Here's some of our own contributions in
this field. This is a G and M model
where you can have a regular grid.
You first encode for every node in the
grid, you encode a feature vector or token,
you put them on the on the on the grid,
then you send messages across the grid,
which makes all the nodes to communicate
with each other, and then you do a final
smoothing using a CNN to predict the next
state of the original model. And this we
could train quite successfully
on irregular grids. Now it's
fun to think about symmetries here,
too, as we did for neural networks,
it's a bit harder to actually include them as
full equivariant solvers. But one thing that
we could do is we could study for a particular
PD, we could study the symmetries. In fact, it's
fully solved problems. You can just delete point
symmetries. You can actually just run a piece of
software. You get all the symmetries out for PDE,
which I didn't know, but was kind of beautiful.
So, you know, all these kind of generators for
each one of the symmetries you can represent
a group of the product of these
generators sort of strung together,
and then basically what we did is we take, we
took original data, and we started to enhance
the data set by applying all of these symmetries.
So you get for free, basically data enhancement,
and then you can solve this. You can train solvers
with much less actual data than you could before.
Now, I guess there's some big successes here,
already going down to 2016 or something.
This was one of the first papers by NVIDIA
group where what's called forecast net is a
model that already globally solved or sort of
predicted the next state of the weather,
like 10 days ahead or something like this,
with these neural free operators. And then
point more weather came slightly after that.
These are all solutions which are completely
based on machine learning. There's no physics
in the actual equations. And then there's
graph cast net, which is a model based on
message passing on a hierarchical multi
scale graph, but this is a DeepMind.
So the contribution we made in the scale was
called Aurora. So the change, what did we do in
Aurora that was different than before? So it was
made so that the encoder could take absolutely any
kind of data. So it could take data from the US
at very high resolution, but local. It could take
global but much more porous data. It could take
all sorts of other data in it would embed all of
that into a latent structure and then basically
a transformer based encoder, and then evolve
that and decode. So the data set is about over
a million hours of data. It was trained in about
38 or something, a 100 GPUs for a few
weeks. So not too terrible. In that sense,
it achieved 5000 times speed up relative to the
normal solver. So that's the big gain you'll
get. You can solve things 5000 to sometimes
10,000 times faster than the original solar
Alright, and then some so. So what this
particular model could do that other models
couldn't do was besides predicting the usual
hydrodynamic variables like wind speeds and
temperature. It could also predict things like
air pollution, concentrating greenhouse gasses,
etc. So by just actually keeping the encoders
the same and just fine tuning the models based
on new data slightly, and so, it could produce
air pollution with very high quality and if.
What's also interesting is that sort of the
standard way is, sort of the simulators for
future, for sort of weather prediction is ifs, H,
R, A, S, which you see here, and lower is better
on these curves for this is surface temperature
and this wind speed, these machine gun walls
actually do better than numerical solvers. You
can use wonder, well, how is that possible?
Since they are largely trained on maybe data,
also from the simulators. But in this case,
of course, there's also real weather data that's
being included into these models. And this real
weather data can actually make it better than
the numerical solvers can, and much faster.
I think that would count as a true change
in the field. I've seen meteorologists
from highly skeptical change to all right?
We really need to do something with this,
because this is actually changing
our field. And then I'll talk a little bit about
some other applications of where AI
has been helping, sort of the sciences,
and also in the other direction, right? So it's
symmetries to improve neural networks. And here,
physics, like non equilibrium thermodynamics,
is also helping build better generative models.
And so the I would say, the arrow, the causal
arrow, goes in both directions. And so in 2013
Dirk came, and I developed this
variation auto encoder model.
And that's a model where you take the distribution
of data and you map it into some latent space,
and then that's the encoder, which is sort of,
this is your semantic representation, if you
wish. And then there's a decoder which samples
from hopefully something very close to that
particular sort of embedded manifold, and then
inverts the encoder into basically sampling back
from a distribution, which is then approximation
to the original data manifold. But it did so in
one stochastic step. So it was a complicated
neural network, but then noise was only added
at the end, and so that evolved into these kind of
diffusion like models where people don't train the
encoder, so we train the encoder. The encoder is
fixed. It's just some fixed process, like wernsten
runbeck process, but you have many stochastic
layers, which gives you embeddings which are
not structured at all. They're just completely
mixed, but they which can very powerfully train
to invert them. And so you can see here an
example, like a two dimensional example of a
data manifold. It gets kind of diffused into sort
of a blurry blob. And so if you look at every day,
it's like a process where you sort of increase
entropy, and then this is a physical process,
if you want, and then you're trying to invert
that. So you're trying to go from heat from this
wall and generate back the manifold. Basically,
by generating training velocity fields for
every point of space, you train a velocity
field, which is now neural net. And he says,
if you're here in this space full of this
velocity field, and then it just put things
back onto this manifold. And by doing this
slowly, step for step, you can really train
very far from all of the good compared to there.
And these authors already acknowledge that that
is actually an application of ideas of non
equilibrium thermodynamics, and that's a field
that is really developing and writing a book about
that also, she'll share a little bit more later,
because these connections between machine
learning and thermodynamics are very,
very deep, actually, in my view. So I would say
that the next step in this development was to
map the problem from a discrete problem to a
continuous problem, SDE governed by Brownian
motion. People know how to invert that.
As a long result, you pick up this extra
term, which is a non, you know, it's a very
non physical process, obviously, because you
go against the second law of thermodynamics.
But mathematically, know how to invert it.
You pick up this term. But it's kind of funny,
because it depends on the actual density itself,
and you don't know it, but the machine learning
model will train this. So you train the model to
approximate the score function, and then you can
run the process and reverse to generate images.
So here's a few equations then. So
there's a very interesting, deep
relationship between machine
learning and and thermodynamics. So I
guess most of us are physicists here,
or mathematicians or chemists or something
like this. So you're probably very used to
these types of equations, right?
This is saying, after equilibrium,
you have a Hamiltonian that describes your system,
and you have a temperature that's connected to the
heat bus, then the distribution of your latent
variables is actually a Boltzmann distribution,
where X might be microscopic variables you
observe like maybe the volume in which everything.
Six, or something like that. And that are
the microscopic degrees of freedom of the
atoms. That's equilibrium distribution, that's
bolt distribution. And so you can write down
a free energy which is minus t, like the low
partition function, which you can lower upper,
bound by a variation of free energy with a
variation of distribution Q, and that's given
by the expectation of the Hamiltonian under that q
minus temperature times the entropy of that Q. Now
if you relax the system, you kick it out of
equilibrium, then Q changes, h doesn't change,
and you relax it back to equilibrium, then
you minimize this variational free energy,
and when Q becomes the Boltzmann distribution,
you're back to the free energy, the minimum,
the energy described by the law partition
function. So work is related, in this view,
by changing this free energy, by changing
the Hamiltonian. If you start changing
the Hamiltonian around by applying forces,
then you're performing work on the system.
And the second ball of thermodynamics follows
from the fact that if you relax this system,
then you will find that always the entropy
of the system and the entropy of the boss,
which is given by basically the heat you're
generating in relaxing relaxing the system back
to equilibrium, the sum of those two will always
be positive, On average, not for any any path,
but on average, with very high likelihood
that's going to be positive. And that
is the second law of thermodynamics. Basically,
we go to the machine learning side. We typically
write in posterior distribution. We use Bayes
rule. So we say, we have some observation x,
you have latent variable z, which could be the
latent variable of some embedding. And we know
by Bayes rule that's given by the Joint divided
by the marginal px. And then you can write down
the free energy, which was done by Jeff Hinton
and referendum a while ago. You can write down
the free energy as minus log of p, which is the
probability of X of the data. And you can upper
bound that by the variational free energy,
again, with some variation distribution Q,
and it's given by the expected value over q
is minus log p the joint minus the entropy.
And if you compare it with this, you can just
read out that h is minus log p of the joint,
and the temperature has to be set to zero,
because there's no real leaf bus in this case.
And here we have a famous algorithm, which is
called the maximum expectation maximization
algorithm from statistics, which says,
if I if I want to learn a system,
I need to do two things. I need to change
the model, p by changing the parameters,
right? That's the M step, and that's performing
work, because now you're changing the Hamiltonian.
And the other step is relaxing the
system by changing Q back to equilibrium,
which is what is we call
inference in these models.
And that's equal to the basically execution of the
second law of thermodynamics. So these two things
match perfectly with each other and the same the
claim is that the mathematics underlying machine
learning, probabilistic machine learning and
graphical models, is exactly the same language
of non equilibrium thermodynamics, and that means
there's a lot of very interesting results we can
import from no income thermodynamics, Like
fluctuation theorems and all these kinds of
things. Okay, so the sort of mapping
of what's been happening recently
in the machine learning field, and my
claim is basically all around free energy.
There is variational inference and machine
learning, MCMC sampling. Those are inference
algorithms. There is reinforcement learning and
optimal control algorithms. There is Schrodinger
bridges in optimal transport. There's
more mathematical sort of concepts, but
they're being used a lot in the machine learning
community, basically. And then there's generative
models like diffusion models and normalizing
flows. And all of these can be understood by
writing down a free energy of this kind, plus
assuming that we have Markov chains over the
latent variable. So we have a we have a generative
process that runs backward in time, if you wish,
it runs against the second law of thermodynamics.
It's like the unscrambling of an omelet,
right? You start with a picking it from a prior
and then moving back to produce things which are
very low entropy. And this is the forward process,
which you start from a data point, and you slowly
deconstruct it by adding noise. If you take these
assumptions and all of these things are become you
can understand this as basically non equilibrium
thermodynamics. I'll talk a few about a few of
these. So clearly the diffusion model, in one
direction, goes from an actual structured object
and destroys it into a blob of noise, right? So
that is entropy production. Basically, that's a
physical process, diffusion.
Unfortunately, this the physical direction.
We all disintegrate at some point, but what
we want is going in the opposite direction
by putting in energy and trying to
construct structure out of noise.
And that's what these generative models
do. They go in the opposite direction of
the second ball. And surprisingly, of course,
by that kind of thing, you can actually generate
images like this, and they're becoming scarily
good these days, which is extremely powerful tool
and but we have also used that to generate
molecules. You can use exactly the same idea
and say, I want a molecule with these properties.
Now train a model that can do that from data,
also be simulated data, and then
you can generate so this is a real,
real process that we've trained. You can
generate these molecules with these properties,
and the matter Gen is now one a version
of that that actually generates materials.
So that idea was also used by Allison,
especially by these two students here at EPFL,
to generate drug life molecules in the
pocket of a protein, right? So you say
this is the pocket of a protein has this
shape. In fact, I have a few components,
maybe anchors, which I want to, in particular,
face places complete the molecule so that it
will actually fit in the pocket and has the
properties that I want. And so for this is
a very early version of that. This model, this
idea, has also evolved already, quite a lot. Now
we look a little bit of optimal
control and showing the bridges. So
this project, well, Project Sisyphus.
This is this poor guy that had to
roll a walk up a mountain, and
then exactly when he was here,
he would always roll back and he
would start again the old greekology.
So that's kind of the fate of a molecule when
it's trying to sample and go from one metastable
state to another metastable state. If you try to
do this by molecular dynamics in your computer,
it will take insanely long, like the age of the
universe, 10 times over something to get there.
And so you need to help it a bit. So you need to
add an extra force to these atoms so that you can
just move it over the over the energy barrier and
get it into the other side. And you can then track
it. Of course, it's a very unlikely event, but
you can track it, you can study it, and then you
can compensate. For the fact afterwards that you
have added all these forces. And so that's called
false integral sampling.
And so the idea is you have an initial stage
for your atoms given by depositions, and now
you follow normal lines of end dynamics, but you
add an extra control term. The extra control term
is nudging the atoms in such a way that you
go over, you to go change the conformation,
or even have a chemical reaction happening at that
space. Either you move it over the energy barrier,
and that's a reinforcement problem, because
you just give the reward for making that
happen in such a way that you do it at the
least possible total energy expenditure.
And so this is a paper that we produce, and
we're still working on similar ideas here,
where this is the free energy landscape,
this is the conformation of the molecule,
and you're driving it, you know, so that
it will get to the other local minima. And
so here it has to be pushed over the over the
energy barrier, and then it gets into the other
local minimum. So again, it goes up and then down.
And now you can study these paths and figure out,
you know, how chemical reactions happen
and what their rates are, for instance.
So, and then here's an application on free
energy. This is a recent paper that just got
accepted in PRL. So this is this application
where you do density functional theory,
but not quantum, but classical. So it's actually
a version that doesn't it's less complicated,
but the mathematics falls extremely follows
extremely similar lines. They write down
the grand canonical potential, which is the
sort of free energy, but with a particle dot,
you write down the free energy for the system
which only models internal interactions,
not the interactions with the external potentials.
And then there's a separate term which in which
models the interactions with some external
potential. Could be a molecule that's fixed,
like adsorption. You want to get a
fixed external potential. You want
to get lots of molecules which kind of
adsorb and a chemical potential. And
of course, you have to write down
this thing was very complicated
because it depends on the properties
of your liquid or your or your gas.
And so what we will do now is learn this
functional, like some of these approaches,
in the quantum of your version as well.
We'll learn that functional from MD data
emulation, right? So you
generate lots of data, like here.
It, and you train the functional neural network,
but within the same framework of distinction
functional theory. And then, once you have that,
you can now basically run an algorithm to
minimize this for a new external potential,
initialize it some row. You
minimize this functional and
get your equilibrium stage. You can even
use it to do dynamics, and it turns out,
and so here's the method
that we developed in a little
bit more detail. And the big advantage here is
that we can train the entire model with
setting all external potentials to zero.
Why is that nice? Because you basically
you can reduce your data set from walls.
So the only thing you need is basically this
radial distribution function, which says,
you know, if you're at the center, you know, my
molecules have a certain size and interaction,
which means that the next molecule needs to
have a little distance from me, which is where
this dip happens. Nothing can be very close.
And then, you know, since it's back, next one is
getting a high probability being at that distance,
etc. This little, you know, line basically gives
us all the information we need in order to compute
the two point correlation functions for this free
energy. And now what we do mg simulations, we
get our densities of every grid point with the
number of particles. Let's say we map it through
a neural network. We do two times out of diff,
which gives us the so we predict the free
energy. Then take two times out of diff to get
the two point correlation function. We can compute
the 2.4 correlation function in theory as well,
using this Kirsten Zirin theorem. And then we
compare the two, and we minimize the difference,
no external potentials, right? We're just looking
at things which are flat, like the bulk. And
we train this, and then once it's trained,
we can now run this equation. It's called the
Picard iteration, which is the same as the self
consistency loop in quantum DFT, which is you
start with some initial density row. You need the
first derivative of the free energy mister section
row, and then you run this to minimize, basically
omega the granola potential. So you now take a new
situation, but with an external potential,
you stick it in, repeat the free energy to
one times. Order to get these derivatives,
stick them in this equation and iteration,
OK. And so
here's one dimensional
examples where this is the true
sort of density. And here the blue line is where
you see it equilibrates Under this process. To
find this equilibrium density, we can now do this
in three dimensions as well. Of course, using all
the symmetries of the system, we can do this now
in three dimensions very, very nicely as well.
And so this got published to PRL very recently, if
you're interested in reading more about this. But
I find this interesting. What I find interesting
about this example is that this was not a very
popular method at all. Nobody used it. Why not?
Because people couldn't write down to write
functionals for free energy. So they wrote down
things which were based on cluster expansions over
there. But they didn't really work well neural
when you use a neural net to train that thing can
be much more expressive, and now suddenly these
methods really started to work well. He's another
example of your machine learning committee.
Take something that didn't work very well and
turn it into something that can actually work
very well by combining the strengths of both,
I would say. Here's some more results. Is also
very interesting. Of course, you can predict free
energies directly in one shot. You don't have
to do both of complicated calculations. I'll
just skip this for a moment, because we're
running a little bit out of time, I think.
And so maybe to start sort of ending a little bit,
I view we are sort of at cusp of a golden age for
material science. A lot of people focus on chat,
GPT and AGI and all these things. But
I think the more interesting part,
I'm sure all of you agreed with me here. I
think the more interesting part is actually
applying these ideas to disrupt the field
of materials and scientific computing.
And,
of course, somewhat dramatically, we've named the
ages in which humanity sort of evolves technology
to the actual materials that they use, from
stone, bronze, iron, plastic, possibly now too,
I would think we're going to enter a phase where
we do material over that. You just tell me what
material you want. There's a search engine
like you would now search for information,
you can search for materials with those
properties, even making sure things are
being synthesizable, et cetera, and it will
give you the answer, so that might dramatically
accelerate the cycle of innovation. And it's of
course, you know the fact that we have these.
Fields which are all about molecular science.
These are all the mature fields
where there's a lot of wisdom.
These are much more young fields,
like computational science. Just heard you
got the biggest supercomputer here on site
that's computational science. Machine
learning is adding to that now, fast
and changing the field. And of course,
hopefully in the future, quantum computing
can also be actually, the first sensible
application of quantum computing is, I think,
too similar quantum mechanics. And then there's
all these applications, which are, I think,
real societal problems that need to be solved
relatively fast around health. You know, maybe
resistant bacteria, antibiotics against
resistant bacteria or pandemics or whatever.
Sustainability you know, getting carbon
out of the atmosphere. Energy sector,
batteries is a great example. There hydrogen
lifting, so hyper hydrogen production using
water splitting, et cetera.
And so this is what we are building at cost.
But this startup that was talked
about is basically a system that
sort of is built on generative AI.
It's generates a foundation model for
generating molecules. It searches in the
space of the space of possible molecules,
and it builds lots of property predictors
to predict, very quickly, the properties or
simulate the systems that are being predicted.
All of that generates data that go back into a
database in which we then improve our models,
and we accelerate this cycle further. First,
there's a search engine around this thing,
which we try to identify materials which are,
which people want to use for certain applications.
And so the last slide is, in my view, there is
a deep connection building between AI and the
natural sciences, and free energy is the
core concept that we need to understand.
And we can see lots of cross
fertilization. Machine learning is helping
the sciences do simulations faster and better.
But these concepts from science, including
symmetries and free energies, but also things
like fluctuation theorems, all these things that
are coming out of non equilibrium thermodynamics,
they also start to bring new concepts to build
better machinery on drugs. And so you could argue
machinery is a new hammer for the scientists
that will develop fast and be quite powerful.
And then maybe the most important part is that
there is lots of really important applications
that can be sold through this in both health
and sustainability, such as developing new
drugs and new materials, and I'll end there
to you some space for questions, fascinating,
very informal,
excited by the results You have done.
Very thankful. Let's have a
training sessions. I do think
there were hands raised up, but before we
go into the online, is there any questions
from the audience in person? Yes. So what
you're saying is, let's say I want a material
that captures carbon dioxide out sky and turns
it into a solid material. Are you saying that,
if those are my parameters, you could create that
material and put in as a parameter to make it the
cheapest possible, way possible? Yes. Well, okay,
how would you train a model? Right? So you have
to break the problem off a little bit. So let's
say so the way we're looking for a certain set
of materials called metal organic frameworks. So
that's this class of materials. So you can train a
foundation model for metal organic frameworks,
so that you can simulate them very fast.
So then
you can and then you need to find the
material, the metal, organic framework,
that absorbs, let's say, carbon dioxide in
natural atmosphere, so where there might
also be a lot of water and other nitrogen in
there, but preferentially takes The side carbon
dioxide and binds it. And then also you need
to, you need to model how it can be released
without using too much energy. If you have
a simulation pipeline for these processes,
right? So you can, if I give you a material, you
can quickly, using machine learning components,
evaluate how good that material is for that entire
process, which is, you could be complicated,
right? Because it could be either simulating,
you know, the adsorption process with the
machine learning force field, or maybe predicting,
like heated adsorption or other kind of properties
or porosity, or whatever, for all of that
material directly with property predictors.
So with machinery modes, you can accelerate
it. Once you have this ability to very quickly
evaluate a material, you can then start
building generative models that generate
lots of candidates, and then start to evaluate
them quickly. And of course, what you really
want is that when you generate these materials,
you want not just random ones. You want the ones
that are guided by your objective function,
which is, I want materials with these specific
properties. You can do this by either conditioning
the model on that information, like a prompting,
if you wish, or guiding the generation in
the direction where you think the interesting
materials are. As the generative model gets better
and better, it produces more and more sensible
search results or molecules, which you still
have to evaluate. But you sped that process up,
too by machine learning methods, and then the
cycle of going around accelerates faster and
faster. So that's the whole process that's being
built. And that's, of course, it's all about,
how do you do one step in that cycle and one going
around, one step very, very fast. Because once you
have these candidates, you want to come up with
a list of candidates and go to the lab and say,
Now please synthesize these. Right? So you have to
think about, are they actually even synthesizable?
How expensive are they de synthesized? Are they
active materials in the real world, which you also
have to simulate? Can you actually put them
in actual machine? Will they remain stable,
or will they disintegrate after a few cycles? All
of these things will have to be simulated, but
then you can optimize against it in silico in
your computer. And by the time you get to the lab,
you say, Now, please synthesize this for me.
You want a very high probability of success,
right? So otherwise, you have to go to the lab
way too many times in the cycle slows down a
lot. So that's that's kind of the process that
we're pursuing. And I think it's a continuous
process. It's not like you flip a coin, you flip
a switch and then everything is perfect. It's
something that continuously improves itself
over time as more data becomes available,
more experiments have been done, but it is
something that can really accelerate the field.
So I was kind of interested halfway through
you talked about how we dropped the physics
from the model and we just train
this solely on data. It seems like,
you know, you're throwing out a lot of the
fundamentals that you kind of know, I
guess, in some sense is there. How would you
I guess it seems like you're missing some of
the physics, and maybe you don't understand
it. So how could you use that to basically
have a model that performs better than your
base understanding to increase it rather
than just drive performance? Yeah, so
that's a great question, and that only
works when you have a lot of data. So
in the case where you don't have a lot
of data, you want to put in a lot of
physics back into the model. But what happens
for these weather prediction models? There's
a lot of actual data out there that's not just
generated by models, right? So this actual data
from the atmosphere, if you wish.
So if you train your models both on predictions
and from actual data, which is basically
what people do. So they basically take these
observations, which are, of course, very sparse,
and then you kind of interpolate all that data
using their simulators to create an initial state,
let's say, for your model, and then they predict
the future. That's the new state, and then again
actual data, and then you correct it again using
the actual data. There's a combination of the
simulation, which you think is interpolation
machine, and the actual data. Now you can see,
if you train your machinery models on that
combination, you can be better than the simulator,
because the simulator doesn't use the data,
the actual observations. The simulator
typically is the laws of physics, right? And
the initial state is the actual state of the
let's say the obtains is obtained by using actual
data, but then the actual predictions are used by
just using navier stokes equation. These models,
even in the way that they evolve the state,
use the actual data and observations, and so
they can actually be better in that sense.
Now there is a danger to all of this as
well, which is, if you don't use physics,
laws of physics, you might get when you get
into new territory, like you've never seen
a very, very hot place before, or maybe the
COVID levels are so high now that you haven't
ever seen it before you do climate modeling, you
could run out of the regime where you've trained
your models. And so reliability and certainty
prediction are really key in this as well,
essentially bounding it with your physics and then
fine tuning with the actual data that you have.
Yeah, I think it can become both
ways. I think it's typically good.
The example is that people have now, so
when you try to put in, say, symmetries,
it seems completely sensible to put symmetries in,
and this is what we've been doing for a long time,
but people are starting to throw out symmetries
when the data sets are very large. And the
reason is, putting in all these constraints
makes these models also harder to learn. And
so they can actually, when you have a lot
of data, the models that throw out all the
physics are actually starting to perform better
now, right? And so this is something to do with
learning dynamics. I think, you know, I think it
depends on will swing back and people say, well,
we can also put the physics back into in other
ways and learn well. And so I think in the end,
it's always a good idea to put in things like
energy conservation, which you really want to
hold in these models. And so there's certain
things which we have to learn how to put back
into these models. But right now is really
it's a battle between easy ways to train very,
very large models and level of the data
versus being trying to be smart with all
sorts of physics information. And it's,
you know, it's a function of how much,
how smart you are with training these models
and how much data you have to pick up.
Kevin, when
you made the connection between this
machine learning and non equilibrium
thermodynamics. Yeah, I think it was
very interesting to me. Do you think this
our knowledge or physics concept from
thermodynamics can help us understanding the
theoretical background of the
machine learning, for example,
the convergence property of the neural networks,
something, yeah, so that's tricky,
though. So I think the field in
physics which is related to the
learning part is called control,
right? So in fact, people do try to control
physical systems, to do certain things for them.
So that's part related to the learning part.
But once you start messing with the
system, it's not just physics anymore,
right? It's like, you know, the learning part is
less physical in the sense because you're trying
to get something from a high entropy state
to a low entropy state. And so that's less
like around what is the theory of physics
that can help here? The other direction,
of course, is exactly physics, but
that's actually in these diffusion models
just wouldn't be Kirsten process, and
it's built very well understood. However,
one direction which we are
going is to think about,
could you, for instance, in the forward process,
an oldenbeck process, it takes infinitely
long to get to a Gaussian distribution,
where we really want this into a finite number
of steps, it needs to happen in a finite number
of steps because that's the computational
resources you have. And so now there is
very interesting work, which is called
optimal transport, where you can show how to
bring one distribution to another distribution
in a finite amount of time, but you have
to apply forces again. So it's more like
a control system. And then the hope could be,
you could show, by the way, that that process
dissipates the minimum amount of work, just
the most efficient way, physically to, say,
change the distribution into another distribution.
Our school also called counter diabetic driving.
So, so now you could hope that this
theory, which tells you something about
dissipation, work, dissipation and heat
generation and whatever is related to,
let's say, variance properties of estimators. And
that's actually true. So it's actually true that,
if you take So, where does heat generation
come from? In thermodynamics, it comes from
fluctuations. If you have the least number of
fluctuations, in fact, what will happen is they
generate the least amount of heat. So these
fluctuations you can show will cause variance
in certain estimators. Let's say you have free
energy differences between two states. So there,
there's a direct relationship between estimation,
statistical estimation, and some physics process.
And now you can start to learn. You can say, Okay,
what did people do in physics to control systems,
to have minimum heat generation? Could
we use those and the theory around
those to help us design better statistical
estimators and better learning algorithms?
Thank you.
I'm sure there are more questions, and also
there are indeed questions from online,
but we do have a next schedule
to cover, so unfortunately,
we have to end it by now. But let me propose
something Max is going to stay here on.
Side the whole afternoon
in this room, actually. So if you have want
to have a more detailed discussion with Max,
I welcome you to come by, starting from 1pm
throughout the whole afternoon. So please
come here and for the participants online.
If you would like to engage the
afternoon sessions, please let me know,
so that I can, you know, send the WebEx the
invitation, so that we can, you can come and
then engage in the discussions as well. So
shall we do that? Yes, okay, well, for the
last closing remark, let's thank
our speaker today. Applause.